so hopefully you're in the right place
this is to talk about beer yeah great
okay I'll try to not run over so you can
go and drink some beer so I want to
start out with a little sort of prologue
about like what motivates this work
which is all sort of done outside of my
day job though using tools from my day
job so so this is my nightmare and the
reason why if my nightmare it's a lovely
pub so I should I should preface by
saying that I'm I live in London though
I'm from the US so if i use strange
words that's why so this is a nice pub
that's not too far from where i work the
problem with it though and the reason
why it is a horrifically envisioned of
drinking is that the the taps there are
the only way that you can make a
decision about what beer you should have
so and they rotate their beer offerings
every couple of days so you've got
something like 20 beers and the the
information you use to make a decision
as a consumer is a little label like
this and this picture is a sort of
historic low turnout for this pub
usually it's like three rows deep so you
can barely see the place never mind
actually work out what you should be
drinking so in contrast to this here is
my favorite menu of all time from a
unfortunately now out of business pub
that was about a mile away from that
first place that we were looking at and
you know don't worry too much about
reading it but the point here is that
there's a bunch of information that you
can see and use to make a decision so
there's like a sentence that describes
what the beer is there's a some
information about the ABV a few other
bits of metadata and like a price point
and how big the sort of decided serving
size for that particular beer is so what
I want to do is think about ways that we
as people who process data and mine
things from the web can automate the
transition from one of those terrible
states to the much better and easier for
consumers to exist in state and so that
leads me to this talk which is really
about sucking up lots of data and
producing a nice summary of that data
where you can use to make meaningful
choices as a consumer that has something
to do
and needs to get on with it fine okay so
so really then this talk is about two
distinct things the first is the domain
beer so lots and lots of beers and in
fact the volume of beer and the fact
that you as someone who is wandering to
a bar you're going to have maybe one or
two decision points maybe more but at
that point probably doesn't matter right
so so that's really I think a critical
thing to keep in mind everything about
this in contrast to consumer choice
ideas in other domains where maybe if
you're listening to music you can sort
of go through a bunch of songs over and
over again in a single session or if
you're on Netflix you can sort of bail
from your film and try another one or
whatever there's lots of iteration
that's possible in a lot of other
consumer choice situations that doesn't
exist in beer so there's a high price of
failure right if you pick two beers and
you realize you made a terrible choice
by the time you're through that beer
that was sort of it for your choices so
everything is of course just volumes of
data lots and lots of text tremendous
amounts of text even more text and then
some more text so the thing that I think
is worth keeping in mind here is that
both these things generalized so as I
sort of hit that while beer is distinct
in sort of choice penalties and things
like this a lot of the ideas can be
applied to other sort of consumer choice
domains a music film certainly other
food drink kind of situations but also
that that the the document summarization
ideas documents are an abstraction idea
so we're going to use documents in a
literal sense we have a piece of text
that feels like a document when you look
at it in the sort of colloquial sense of
a document but it is just a group that
is semantically meaningful of objects
right so so people can people have used
these sorts of methods to do screwy
things with say PCM audio and things
like this so I just just keep in the
back of your head that a lot of the sort
of things that we're doing if we change
the sort of front and back the the
pre-processing and the presentation
layer can apply to a world of different
kinds of data streams the other thing is
that this talk is informal I'm going to
talk about a lot of math if you really
want to know more about lda i really
hope you were sitting in your very seat
about 25 minutes ago
Tim the lovely guy who just spoke before
me gave a really good sort of generative
exploration of what lda is there's lots
of other research on resources on that
and some of the other ideas that were
going to talk about we're going to spend
very little time on the mathematical
models and a lot more on the sort of
what you do with them and how you can
get your data in a place where it will
be coherent through the model okay so
with that in mind let's talk about beer
for a couple of minutes because that's
the domain we're interested in and so
it's important I think for everyone to
have some kind of overview about what
we're dealing with here so beer really
is just four ingredients so you've got
water which is ninety percent of beer
and makes a great deal of difference the
sort of mineral contents inside of the
water all the sort of thing will have a
big impact on things you've got mult
malt here for its cut sorry I just I
forgot the question can I ask how many
of you have ever made beer in your house
okay great biases in that direction okay
so so so so mult is cereal grains right
everything that you make bread with you
can make beer with you know the classic
ones are barley which is the principal
one that you make beer out of also wheat
you can make beer out of corn though you
probably shouldn't you can you can make
beer out of rye that's quite nice
sometimes also like more exotic grains
get used when they're malted sorghum for
instance which is a grain from Africa
there's a list anything you can sort of
extract starches from that is a grass
seed you can theoretically make beer out
of those some obviously work better than
others malting is simply a process of
tricking that seed into thinking that
it's a good time to turn into a plant so
like what we've done is through heat and
water said like hey grass seed your it's
time for you to turn into a blade of
grass and then right when it's about to
do it you burn it and then and so what
you're going to do converted this like
starch reservoir into a pile of sugar
and the pile of sugar in later parts of
the process turns into alcohol and
that's that's how the beer works so hops
are the sort of in a lot of like modern
especially American craft beer the
hofstra thing hops are an herb they
provide bitterness to sort of complement
other things going on in a beer
they're very closely related to
marijuana so they can be kind of mellow
they have a lot of interesting flavors
that we will see when we starts tracking
the topics from our documents things
like sort of pine smells also big citrus
notes stuff like this but they're very
oily they're very bitter and it's where
everything that is not sweetness and
booze and body come from in the beer the
other thing is yeast yeast is a lovely
single cellular organism and it does all
the work so it takes all the sugar it
eats the sugar it excretes alcohol so
when you drink any alcoholic beverage
you are drinking the excrement of yeast
it is delicious so there are four steps
I kind of hinted at them through the
ingredients so you mash things so you
take all your all your grass seeds and
you soak them in some hot water and that
gets everything going so that converts
the latent energy into a useful form for
the yeast once you've done that that
takes a little time then you boil it the
boiling does a couple of things it's
where you add the hops that impart
bitterness so there's a chemical
reaction that converts the oils that
exist in the hops to something that's
perceived as bitter it also breaks down
some proteins although more of that
happens a little later as well and then
once you've boiled things you add the
yeast the yeast does its work this takes
a few days it's called fermenting it's
lovely smells really good and then you
package it after all that's done you
stick it in a bottle or you stick it in
a cagar used to get in the cask if
you're in the sort of place where casks
are a thing and that's where the
carbonation gets well not add it because
it was there anyway but that's where it
gets kept so that it can impart a
certain sort of flavor to your beer so
you've got basically for ingredient
classes and then for big steps for
process and from those reasonably small
things you have a tremendous variety of
beers and so the thing about beer is
that there are a lot of people who are
very obsessed with beer and I mean like
people that make my obsession levels
look mild and amateur and and so here
what we have is a couple of people who
are judging volumes of beer this is
something I do on the weekends also
I should say so they've got this is a
Best in Show judging competition so
they've got little like two ounce things
of about 25 different beers that all won
their little category and they're going
through them and they're sniffing them
and they're rolling them around in their
mouth and they're writing like three
pages of text about them right and then
grading so so okay that's fine but but
they're doing that with a pencil on a
piece of paper and that's not actually
useful for our sort of motivating goal
from earlier on in the talk so I'm gonna
spend a little bit i'm talking about a
website called ratebeer it is not the
only place where this sort of behavior
goes on but what this basically is is a
website for the kind of people who spend
their weekends judging beer and thinking
that's a good use of their time so
rapier has you know the kind of metadata
that you expect about beer abv the
brewer that makes it you know these
sorts of things but the and also up here
you can see so so in a way that's very
you know Netflix eh this kind of thing
lots of modern consumer web sites
there's ratings and it compiles the
ratings it does a sensible bit of
Statistics where it actually gives users
of the website more value if they've
been contributing for a long time so
that thing that says weighted average up
on the screen know if you can see it
from way in the back that actually does
not equally wait an average everyone it
sort of works out if you're a good user
of the website and then binds things
together but actually that's not really
what we care about here although there's
a wealth data that's interesting what we
actually care about is if you scroll
down the page on a ratepayer beer
listing you get this big block of text
toward these big by sort of
user-generated content review kind of
sites and because of a bunch of you I
conventions on rape beer it really
encourages you to take the thing you're
rating and sit down at a table and have
a think and write like 200 words and so
people have done this lots and lots and
lots of people so and in fact for for
that particular beer there's about 2,000
reviews and they're all about that
volume so you've got two to four
sentences from a bunch of different
users and addition to the ratings you've
got this big descriptive text so let's
let's poke a little bit more at another
beer from from ratebeer this is a kernel
export stout which is from a brewery
that's not far from where I live it's
very lovely dark beer that in spite of
being
the stout actually has a pretty big hop
aroma which makes it kind of interesting
because it's a little bit of a sort of
push against the style conventions for
what a stout can be expected to taste
like and it also doesn't get around very
much so almost everyone who reviews that
either is a beer nerd who sort of like
pull some favors and get someone to
bring them one or lives in the local
area because they don't export this beer
so so we can see the reviews here I'll
read a couple so the first one says
triga like viscous thick a dark brown or
black cream brown head can't think of
much to improve here bitter and sweet
and mineral oil and perfect harmony
right so he clearly liked that beer you
know there's there's a bunch of other
things uh so we can sort of pick out
some some some flavor notes there's a
big aroma some some ash eNOS dark
chocolate notes strong coffee right that
gives you kind of an idea of of the idea
of the beer so if we take that text me
just extract the text Adam ignore all
the context we sort of get something
like this but actually what we have is
something like this now in the back that
might just look like white fuzz that's
every single piece of text that was
written about this beer by everyone from
rape beer so clearly that's not quite
enough and in general in fact lots of
people write lots of things about beer
so if what I want is a quick and easy
consumer decision kind of tool we need
to do something with this we can't just
simply sort of you know pull out our
phone and go to rape beer and go through
each of the 20 beers and read 2000
reviews and make it that mean is is not
going to work okay so text processing
let's talk about text processing so in
particular we're going to look at the
sort of broad natural language
processing ideas which is what NLP
stands for and we're really interested
in in one particular field within NLP
which is called document summarization
and again I document is in quotes here
because we're talking about text but it
doesn't have to be text right anything
you can represent as a stream of data
can be a document that can be summarized
through these methods so one of the
things that that's really general in
almost any kind of data from the wild
NLP process which certainly needs
anything where you're gathering all
data from the web is that you're going
to spend ninety percent your time
ninety-five percent your time trying to
pre-process your data so before we do
all of the fancy statistics that
everyone's been talking about we have to
make sure that the data we're giving to
our statistical models makes any kind of
sense is normalized in any kind of
fashion has weird character encoding
problems pulled out that it doesn't have
Aaron HTML tags why there's all kinds of
crap and it's it's littering our data
and we get to get rid of it so the first
step is something called tokenization I
suspect this crowd actually knows what
organization means really what
tokenization is is it really over the
considered way of saying that we're
going to break on white space and then
we're going to lower all of our
characters to lowercase right like this
right that's that's whatever anyone says
tokenization they're just trying to feel
fancy and they're just doing this right
so or well mostly so so we can actually
be a little bit more sort of savvy than
that we can use a language processing
library here i'm using NLT k later i'll
use another package called spacey
they're both doing roughly the same kind
of thing so here what we have is we have
a tokenizer that understands punctuation
and a few other things and is breaking
on all the ways that words are separated
in written language and throwing out all
those intermediary characters so you
what you get is reasonably clean words
and then we're lowering everything
because we you know if someone says
black at the front of a sentence we want
it to mean the same to our model as
black at the beginning or in the middle
of the sentence Cuse me and and the
reason for that is because as was
discussed in the last talked we're
throwing out all the sequence data right
so so what we're going to end up with in
a little while is a bag of words
representation just word counts for our
documents right so we can be even a
little bit more savvy we can get rid of
words that are useless in our
understanding of things we can get rid
of punctuation etc you can you can spend
quite a lot of time on this and actually
this is one of the places where you can
get pre domain-specific so in this case
because what we really care about here
is descriptors of things so really in
this application we're using reviews as
a proxy for content description right so
so what we want here is a collection of
terms that describe
in physical space so what we're going to
do here what what this slightly messy
list comprehension is is is tokenizing
and then using part of speech analysis
which tells you if something is a noun
or a past participle or an adjective or
adverb and it's throwing out everything
that is not strictly a noun or adjective
because since what we're doing here
ultimately is proxy descriptive terms we
don't care about those and ann's and
always and very we care about black and
brown and malt and hop right and so so
we're going to end up throwing out about
half of our words from our corpus but
what we're left with is the part of the
corpus that matters for this kind of
thing and in fact because we're doing
this this sort of bag of words goes from
a weakness for strength because really
what we want is counts of descriptive
words right and that's that's all we're
trying to do here so so this is I think
the reason why I'm sort of picking at
this is because what this is is it's
applying domain knowledge to the
statistical process in a way that makes
the statistical process have to do less
work right and I think that's going to
yield some success okay so we have all
of this pre-processing now what are we
going to do with it so the simplest way
that we can take all of these piles of
words and counts and give them some kind
of meaning something called tf-idf so
I've given this talk to beer nerds
before and I suspect it's going to be on
its head how many of you have ever done
something with tf-idf nevermind
know-it-all great it's a hundred sent
super okay so we'll fly through this
part then okay so TFI you have his term
frequency inverse document frequency
here's a little model of it basically
you count up how many documents are it
appears in then you take each individual
document and you do account for the
words there you get a little fractional
waiting if we do a little example in
beer we'll go back to our exports stout
and so we have this big volume words
right big volume words is too much
reading so what we can do is is through
tf-idf and our pre process will end up
with some words and some weights so
similarly to sort of the the particular
little sample that I took and read at
you we've got coffee as the moat as the
highest weighted word by the ste of IDF
process then chocolate and black dark
licorice espresso
cocoa brown bitter spoke whatever so I
don't know I don't know about everyone
in the audience but whenever I see sort
of tf-idf process words I always sort of
get a flashback to to like days gone
late 90s and I make word clouds right
and and and so so here we have the sort
of top 10 weighted terms in a word cloud
which I've just noticed like there every
now and again you see this sort of like
look I can make word class lot of
collections of text and there was one
going around Twitter and I'm like how we
said 1997 I don't understand what we
need to move on but anyway so this is a
reasonable way to represent things I
suppose but the problem here is that the
computer is really not clever so so you
and I as humans we can sort of work out
that some of these words kind of mean
the same thing they correlate in certain
ways they get used to describe the same
kinds of things we look at this a word
cloud here what we have is we have
overlapping terms right so we've got
this little note of espresso but also
this coffee we have black and dark and
brown that are all describing a certain
sort of quadrant of color we have cocoa
and chocolate okay so what can we do so
we can do topic modeling right sorry so
I live in Britain we can do topic
modeling um I have to remember what
Potter cited and I think I'm on ok so
topic modeling who in this room wasn't
here for the talk beforehand the last
doc it's like half ok so so to review
the broad high-level idea of topic
modeling is that you have instead of
just describing how likely different
words are and how much sort of meaning a
word has in a document which is
basically what tf-idf does how
differentiating awards usages for a
particular document among a corpus you
have this intervening which is what we
have here you have this intervening idea
where what you want to do is first
workout how often words occur together
roughly again this is informal and then
you use that to build this notion of
topics so if if if you notice that black
and dark get used together on a regular
basis then those are probably in the
same topic right and that's that's
really what the inference models of
topics are doing is they walk through
your corpus and they work out how likely
words are to occur together ish kind of
okay so so once you've done that then
you do that with all the reviews right
so you build up this notion of what kind
of words are used together notionally in
individual documents across your whole
corpus of documents and then that gets
you topics and you can infer them in a
few different ways there's plenty of
resources to work out that if you have
sort of you want to talk to me about
ways to infer takats we can talk about
that later that's outside the scope of
the talk but so if I do this on my on my
beer corpus you get these sort of topic
that our group together these are topics
and the are the top five words and a
topic and the probability that they
occur given a topic so we've got you
know as expected you've got this
grouping of like sort of color and aroma
that couple together force of chocolate
dark kind of beers and then a similar
but not quite the same dark smoky note
and then this one down at the bottom
citrus hop grapefruit orange pine for
people that drink a bit of craft beer
will recognize that as a particular kind
of hop aroma that is frequently found in
stuff like IPAs okay so topic modeling
is an activity that's that's the first
step you've got your topics but then
what you're gonna do is you're going to
describe a document as a mixture of
topics instead of directly as a bunch of
weights of words like you would do if
you're doing TF idea so so how do we do
that so we're going to use a process
called latent dirichlet allocation and
latent dirichlet allocation uses
derivative models which are a
statistical abstraction to find your
latent variables and so if we look at
what a duration that is so Jerusalem is
a is basically just two discrete
probability and this is how we're going
to model both our topics and our
documents in el día and so here we have
some colors some blocks of color they
have probabilities for being in this
document and so we can notionally think
of this idea of if we sort of kick the
document what color is going to come out
right it's going to be blue is going to
be pink is it going to be black or white
and we've got some probabilities for
that okay so this is not anything that's
that revolutionary but if we sort of
back off to talking about topics and
documents two layers effectively each
one of those blocks instead of having a
known color distribution is a
distribution of
tributions and so you sort of am it
twice effectively right you've got two
different layers again this talk is
informal if you wanted some of the mat I
hope you were here last hour for the
last talked and you know feel free to
dive into this in depth later so okay so
we have made some topics we've made some
documents about some topics what can
that tell us for beer summarization so
let's go back to this kernel exports
doubt it's pretty nice we have this
massive pile of words it's too many
words we can't read it so the exports
that has like these are the four top
topics and actually I should step back
and point out that one of the things
that is very hard to do in topic
modeling is display the topic in a way
that's coherent it has meaning so that
what I'm doing in this talk is following
a convention when people talk about
topic modeling and just displaying the
words that are most prevalent in the
topics but that's actually not
necessarily the like correct semantic
thing to do to explain what the topics
about so apologies but anyway so we have
a dark sweet sort of raising things so
this is this idea of like a fruity dark
thing and then we have this other sort
of fruit note that's more actually from
hops this fruit peach tropical mango
apricot that's a hop note and then
another hob note which is pie in citrus
and then this this fourth topic is
interesting this for topic is not so
much about flavor but about texture and
appearance right so this is a beer
that's thick and so it's it's got good
head retention and it pours well so
they're talking about the texture in the
appearance in that in that fourth topic
right okay so so if we think back about
the domain I was talking about out there
were four sort of prevalent ingredients
can we find topics that clearly
correspond to those ingredients right if
we think about what this topic modeling
process can tell us about our domain so
we've got water hops malt and yeast and
so here's a hops topic there are a few
of them you saw that in that last
description as well here's what about
malt so we've got caramel amber malts
wheat copper covers an appearance note
but that's clearly something that's
coming from your malt characteristics so
yeast so does anyone does anyone
understand in the in the crowd why I've
put banana and clove and bubble gum
which one is
certainly seem like things that have
anything to do with microbes into the
yeast category does anyone does anyone
like german wheat beer and a show hands
all right so if anyone ever like
described what they what they sort of
smell and taste from a german wheat beer
as banana or clove yeah okay so so that
comes from from the yeast that is used
to ferment wheat beers typically and
there's an interaction that happens with
nitrogen this is not a chemistry
conference I won't get into it but
basically that that chemical reaction
produces the thing that is perceived in
your mouth and then in your brain as
clove and banana and in fact bubblegum
as well and the difference between those
three flavors has to do with the parts
per million that's present in the beer
so it's all just the same chemical
because brains are crazy so so banana
and clove which I don't think a lot of
people group together cycle physically
are actually from the same chemistry and
it's just a perception issue and a sort
of density of that chemistry so actually
this is a very satisfying thing that
these things get grouped together as a
topic because you expect them to come
from the same class of beers so this is
a good sort of sanity check in a lot of
ways right okay so and then water okay
so so what I've put here for water is a
little bit it's a little little dubious
but but i'm gonna i'm going to push on a
little bit and the reason is because
what we have here is we're describing
the sort of nothingness beers and will
will cycle back on this a little bit but
when you when you look at beers that are
soft that are i think i think in in the
US there's a term a lot more beer which
is great so so this is from what where
water is most important so so you do not
have other things to cover up the
softness and mineral character of your
water right and and this is the sort of
descriptor you expect ish kind of from
here okay so so let's let's talk about
the topic of the talk so so great taste
less wordy or actually to make the
reference slightly more explicit less
filling so there's been a branding
campaign that's gone on for nearly the
entire time that I've been alive by a
company that ostensibly makes beer
and and so so what I want to do is see
if we can use this tool to better
understand what great tastes is less
filling so let's look at miller lite so
miller lite is on trade beer in spite of
its general obsessive nature it does
actually cover pop beer as well it's not
just for indie bands I mean beer and so
okay so half half of half of the topic
when you're looking at the reviews is
white light clear golden and watery now
now that's the same topic by the way
that I stuck on for water just a minute
ago so nine percent comes from this sort
of gold and white grassy light pale
which is a very similar topic so I ran I
ran the topic analysis with a hundred
topics because it seemed to do about
right in terms of topic separation so
one of the ways that you can sort of
qualitatively work out topic numbers is
by seeing how separate your topics are
is idea that like if things are
reasonably dispersed across your word
space it's about the right number of
topics ish now these two things overlap
clearly but they're kind of talking
about different aspects of the beer
right one is one is a little bit more
concerned with aroma and the other one
is a little more concerned with texture
or in this case the sort of lack of
texture right so that grassy note is a
big hint about aroma as opposed to
texture ok so then we've got another one
this is seven percent and it's like a
head description a little bit of color
and last we've got a sort of little bit
of a flavor knows it's kind of maybe
backing off our sort of assertions and
that that's nearly like that have enough
to write off the rest of the topics are
all much lower so you've got again it's
100 topics so that's really the bulk of
the descriptive character ok so let's
let's have a little epilogue about
similarity so in the abstract of this
talk I said that we could use these
methods to actually compare how
different different beers are or at
least how different the beer reviews
about different beers are because
remember we're just talking about the
proxy here we're actually sticking beer
in sort of a spectrometer and measuring
characteristics of beer directly okay so
so actually if I restate this what I
really mean here is that I have the same
taste and you've changed your beer menu
if I know what I like from your venue
before how can I workout without doing
an exhaustive brute force sample what I
like from your list now so we're going
to look at vector space models which
actually is what we've been doing
quietly for a lot of these things before
but let's pick at it a little bit so a
vector space model is an idea where you
have a bag of words and what you're
gonna do is you're going to project that
bag of words into an n-dimensional space
where n is the your vocabulary in the
most direct sense and and you know there
are reasons why we might need to not do
that directly but we'll just sort of
keep things simple and talk about it
directly first so if we have a tour
example we have this is this is all the
sentences that are possible in this sort
of fictional world again and I did not
talk to Tim who gave the last talked I
didn't know he was also going to use
emoji words but it's quite pleasing to
know that he and I seem to be in the
same headspace about this so so here
there are two words in a whole language
the words are sunglass smiley and sad
cat and that's that's apparently enough
to describe all notions in the universe
and then these three sentences are sort
of our corpus right so so we've got you
know a sort of five smiley sunglass 3
cap notion and down to sort of even and
other things so what we can do in a
vector space here now conveniently it's
almost like I did this on purpose since
there are only two words in the whole
language we can just put this on a graph
which is great so this is a vector space
model in a two-word language with no
like crazy projections to your head
around but this is all vector space
models are you take the words and you
just put them on a graph so well this is
the so I can measure the distance
between those points right ok so in fact
in general from this graph from this
vector space projection we can work out
the sense one is more similar to
sentence to than sentence three right
which if we go back and look at them
remember bag of words it simply just
counts right and the counts of words
incense is one and two are more closely
aligned than either with sentence three
ok so the reason why we have to do vsm
not directly on word counts and on
vocabularies directly is something
called the curse of dimensionality does
anyone in the room know
I mean run talk about Chris I mention
allottee anybody do similarity
measurements okay so it's basically if
the statistical notion that when you
have very very high dimensional space
everything ends up being very close to
everything else as a really fun
mathematical proof to get sort of get
your head around but basically if if you
have a ten thousand dimensional space
there's no point in measuring distance
because everything is kind of uselessly
close to everything else and so if we
have ten thousand words because we're
looking at spoken English we have to do
something before we do this vector space
projection or there's no point in taking
distances so topic models and a few
other there's there's a bunch of
strategies for doing this topic models
is one because what we end up with is
documents that have hundred dimensional
space which is much better than 10,000
or 100,000 dimensions so okay now
practical advice so I'm from London I
know what beers I like that are
available in London but I'm not in
London right now and I'd like to have
some idea of what things I should maybe
be questing for from the better craft
beer bars in the area so I can take and
I can answer this question with my data
right um what New York beers what beers
produced in New York are similar to the
colonel export stout by this review
process so this is answerable with a
vector space model and just a simple geo
filter off the metadata that I've
collected from right beer right and so
the code to do this is like 20 lines
right so so this is all the code that
we've talked about this is the pre
process half and then you build the
model that's the last step down at the
bottom building lady lda model it's
really simple to pre-process we're just
cutting up all of our data we're
throwing out all the words that are
below two characters because we assume
they're not actually that useful
otherwise we're not doing any filtering
and then the sort of business end of
things we build a similarity matrix
which is just simply measuring in that
projected hundred mention 100
dimensional space how far apart using
cosine distance points are and then
we're pointing out which which place the
colonel beer is there we're measuring
the colonel beers distance from all the
other beers in the space and then we're
throwing out the beers that are not
produced by a brewery that is based in
the state of New York which is that
business that I'm pulling from the SQL
database
as an aside it's to SQL calls because
this is all an SQL Lite and doing the
join is actually tremendously slower
than working this out in Python you know
which is I there I cared enough I could
put this in Postgres but this works so
okay so let's look at that so these are
the five beers that one that metric and
their similarity scores to the colonel
beer now one of the things that I find
as someone who spends too much time you
know thinking about beer kind of
fascinating is actually a bunch of these
beers especially the first one are not
the same style but this makes sense
because the colonel export stout is
quite a bit hoppier than a lot of things
that are called stouts so what you have
here is a black IPA which for people who
aren't style nerds is a sort of emergent
style that's kind of like a stouter
reporter but maybe not quite as thick
and full of hops like you would get in a
paler beer and then you've got a vanilla
porter I don't know what the crack is
doing in this list but you know everyone
is fallible maybe the topics we're not
quite clean and then a couple of triples
which are Belgian styles and you know
not quite the same sort of thing but a
little bit different and yeah so you
know all of these in fact I can I can
pull up some of these beers we can look
at them on ratebeer if I quickly go away
because I have a couple minutes so so
here's the the Heartland Black IPA one
of the things that I really like
actually about this method of similarity
is that it pulls up beers that if I was
using a social similarity metric like
through collaborative filtering or
something which of course is possible
with this set because we've got lots of
ratings wouldn't get pulled up because
these things are just not that popular
so so this completely it ignores both
sort of positive negative judgments so
you'll find a couple of the beers on
that list are like really low down in
the rating they're like two and and that
carnal beer is quite highly rated and
also like low rating so this is this how
it has 9 ratings if we look at a vanilla
porter it's got 37 a few but not Lots in
fact this crack is got 19 which might be
why it ended up on there and then these
that the omagon is a little bit more
popular and also quite well considered
fine and that's that's about it it's 542
so I think I'm about
so I'll happily take some questions if
we have a couple and thanks a lot ah
could some of the taste come from air
salt humidity by the ocean etc um yes so
do you mean the taste that someone who's
tasting a beer gets or the taste that
the brewer sort of gets in the beer
could you have put any of the topics
under that category as opposed to for
the you chose ah I see um yes so so that
was definitely a qualitative exploration
of the topics and not like a sort of
good so I didn't so you want you can do
clustering of your topics and actually
like something to do from here that
would be a bit more rigorous is to see
if if the there's a clusters of topics
describing the same kinds of things
which is which is something you can do
and then what you'd expect to see is is
some of the topics that talk about
certain elements within the beer to
cluster together so like a Roma focused
topics or things that are very concerned
about malt are going to end up clumped
together maybe although I haven't run it
it's possible the things would actually
drift by style or by locale so there's a
bunch of other things that can drive
word usage because at some level what
we're talking about here is linguistics
as much as it's beer right so it's
entirely reasonable for the data for
instance to shake out by geography as
opposed to buy beer style right so so it
doesn't seem unreasonable that people
talk about beer in ways that are defined
not so much by the beer but by whether
or not they live in New York or Belgium
right and and so you know that's that's
one possible explanation for some of the
deviation and there are ways to sort of
look at that a clustering is an
immediate answer but there are a few
other ways you can sort of pick that
apart as well hang else so when we're
going to get beer similarity as a
service oh man like we can have a talk
afterwards that's something I would love
to do um
there are there are in all seriousness
there are a few like commercial attempts
I I think they're still a lot of work to
be done in the space there's there's a
mobile service called untapped in
addition to ratebeer there's another
organization called called beeradvocate
rapier and beer advocate are the two
sort of like old guards in this space
they've had like lamp stack websites for
about 15 years longer I think I think
both of them are mid-90s untapped is
newer and mobile first but they don't
they're not rigorous with their data as
I think the polite way to put it so so
theoretically they have like a
recommendation service they give you
recommended beers right when you've
checked in a beer which is roughly the
opposite of what I want someone to help
me decide on a beer and there's a bunch
of sort of strange things that happen
with that service and I think you know
there's a lot of potentially empty empty
space in the area so yeah so you made a
point to mention that a lot of these
techniques generalize well beyond direct
NLP applications so did you have any
examples in mind that you could provide
sure so there there have been some
examples of people using a topic
modeling to do things like develop
distance metrics for playlists so
there's some work well I'm the first
author of the work which is why I know
of it that takes that takes audio
thumbnails in sequences and uses a
sequential distances that are projected
down into lower distant spaces using an
Lda model and then measures the distance
between those spaces and uses that as a
distance metric for playlists of audio
there's also been some work in the same
sort of circle that uses tags so
freeform tagged texts as opposed to
prose text which is another step away in
combination with audio to do similar
kinds of distance metrics I've seen some
work that uses social network analytics
is the first step so actually what you
do is look at features of nodes and
graphs and then from that you use topic
model analysis to do dimensional
reduction basically anywhere where you
have too many dimensions and you want
quite a few less and you think there is
some semantic intermediary level there's
a potential application for topic
modeling situations where you have
counts of too many things yeah that's
right um yeah okay thank you thanks a
lot
you